qu'est ce que tu veux faire quand tu
seras plus grands cette question vous
l'avez tous entendu moi aussi quand
j'étais à l'école et même après alors je
me souviens dans ma classe j'avais les
pompiers les astronautes
les vétérinaires les grands classiques
moi j'avais envie d'être souffleur de
verre
pourquoi pas pourquoi est-ce que je
ramène cette question sur le tapis
aujourd'hui parce que c'est une des
premières questions qu'on vous pose qui
est une question de la finale design
c'est à dire que le but de cette
question c'est d'essayer de vous amener
à réfléchir sur à quoi voulez vous que
votre vie ressemble
qu'est ce que voulait faire en fait plus
tard alors cette question spécifiquement
pour moi les deux gros problèmes
la première c'est que l'on limite votre
vie à votre carrière parce que quand on
vous demande ce que vous comptez faire
plus tard on s'attend pas à ce que vous
parliez d'où vous allez habiter avec qui
vous allez habiter
qu'est ce que vous faites sur notre
temps libre ou est-ce que vous passez
vos vacances etc et pourtant ça fait
partie de ma vie
bien entendu le deuxième problème c'est
que on parle de carrière qui sont quand
même très spécifique je parlais tout à
l'heure des vétérinaires des astronautes
on pourrait rajouter les avocats les
docteurs etc
alors cette amitié qui existe bien sûr
ils ont leur formation ils ont tout un
système qui existe mais beaucoup d'entre
vous ont compris maintenant que la
plupart des métiers au jour
d'aujourd'hui c'est une liste
d'objectifs à atteindre de problèmes à
résoudre on trouve quelqu'un qui peut le
faire on lui donne un titre ouf ça y est
on a un nouveau métier et bah quand on
vous demande qu'est ce que vous voulez
faire dans la vie ou qu'est ce que vous
faites dans la vie ça c'est la version
que l'on vous pose peut-être
actuellement on prend pas vraiment sa
rencontre
donc pour moi le problème de fond est
que cette question là c'est que si vous
essayez de construire votre vie en vous
posant cette question mais si on trouver
une réponse à cette question là bas pour
certains d'entre vous ceux qui ont une
vie qui se résume à autre chose que leur
travail et qu'ils cherchent un métier
qui n'est pas extrêmement spécifique
savait difficile de trouver une réponse
il ya un deuxième modèle qui vous
connaissez aussi et qui pour moi est un
petit peu meilleur c'est le modèle vie
privée vie professionnelle
certains pensent que ces deux concepts
opposés d'autres qui sont
complémentaires certains se définissent
comme étant un côté de l'autre peu
importe ce qui est intéressant avec ce
concept là c'est que tout à coup ça y
est on a conclu on inclut la vie privée
donc c'est déjà pas mal et ensuite on
inclut tous les types de métiers
donc il ya pas mal de gens qui trouvent
leur compte je sais que ce n'est pas le
cas pour moi m'a fallu un moment pour
trouver ça je me suis rendu compte que
la vie d'aujourd'hui et dont je vous
parlais dans une minute ne rentre ni
dans le premier modèle dans le deuxième
et donc justement j'ai développé un
troisième modèle et c'est ça que
j'aimerais vous présenter aujourd'hui en
espérant que ça pour en aider certains
d'entre vous
bacon sur la vie dont vous rêvez alors
un petit historique rapide
ma relation à l'école ça a toujours été
un petit peu tendu quand j'étais au
collège au lycée tout ça jeu bon je
m'ennuyais mais l'école c'était
obligatoire c'est ce qu'il fallait faire
puis après quand j'ai quand même décidé
de poursuivre des études puisque j'ai
fait un master pourquoi parce que ça me
servir d excuse ça me donner un statut
le statut étudiant ça m'a permis de
rencontrer des gens de me faire des amis
de partir à l'étranger effectivement
j'habite en suède actuellement à ça a
commencé avec mes études mais bon
séparément l'action éclaté moi je
m'éclatais dans tout un tas d'activités
périphériques que j'avais autour alors
on peut on pourrait parler effectivement
de la rédaction d'un roman composition
musicale tourner des films des choses
comme ça où vraiment je me faisais
plaisir et puis en 2012 juin 2012 quand
j'ai eu mon master j'ai dit j'en ai
marre de ce style de vie parce qu'à
cette espèce de gros behemoth là qui
prend plein de temps les études qui
m'apporte pas grand-chose perso donc ce
que je vais faire c'est que je vais
fusionner tous âges avant une activité
donc une carrière un truc qui me prend à
les 40 heures par semaine mais vraiment
où je m'éclate comme ça j'ai plus besoin
d'avoir ses activités extérieures
et puis sur le temps libre et bages
passerelle tant est que ma famille avec
mes amis et c'est bon ça c'était la
théorie plus facile à dire qu'à faire
puisque j'ai passé un an à chercher un
travail sans sens sans succès puis après
j'ai monté mon entreprise j'ai travaillé
sur différents projets effectivement
j'ai passé avec l'as des alpes un temps
pour ceux qui connaissent j'ai bossé
avec une entreprise coréenne qui étaient
intéressés pour venir en europe et je
fais beaucoup d'autres d'autres choses
beaucoup de projets en foire et c'est
souvent comme ça pour ceux qui se
mettent à leur compte un fouet de près
en général ça foire au début après j'en
ai quelques uns qui ont fonctionné mais
ce qui est intéressant c'est que aucune
activité que j'ai lancé n'avait ce côté
saint graal acquis qui me permet de
faire tout ce que j'ai envie c'est super
je lui passais 40 heures par semaine
c'est cool et en fait il m'a fallu un
bon moment c'est ans et l'année dernière
2010 8 30 en 2018 ou trois coups j'étais
une période où il y avait plusieurs
d'activité qui commençait à pop et à
droite à gauche qui était sympa et je me
suis dit mais en fait effectivement si
je pense chaque activité en soit je
pourrais pas passer quarante heures
dessus je vais m'ennuyer mais par contre
si je les combine toutes ensemble et si
je passe un petit peu de temps sur
chaque chaque jour chaque semaine chaque
mois
là tout d'un coup c'est cool là tout à
coup c'est sympa alors à quoi ressemble
la vie aujourd'hui je vous donnais juste
un petit exemple pour que vous
compreniez ce dont je parle
il faut générer un revenu d'accord donc
généré revenus principalement avec du
travail de voix aux fêtes doublage est
un petit peu de
de traduction un autre truc important
pour moi c'était de contribuer à la
société est aussi d'utiliser mes
compétences en leadership en management
du coup j'ai monté une association en
suède où j'habite qui utilisent des jeux
de société en fait pour accueillir les
gens qui viennent d'arriver en ville et
puis les aider à se faire des amis j'ai
aussi ce besoin de connaître des gens
étrangers de faire connaître à
l'étranger du coup je fais des voyages
un petit peu longera mois pour créer des
contacts sur place
et puis j'ai ce vieux rêve de faire de
mon roman une série d'animations donc du
coup je suis en train de préparer un
document pour démarcher des boîtes de
prod donc tout ça c'est ce que je fais
alors je plaide pas dire que je vais
tous les jours mais sur une semaine je
travaille un petit peu sur tout ça et il
y en a encore d'autres
et là où je veux revenir si on revient à
ce que j'étais en train de dire au début
c'est que si vous me demandez au jour
d'aujourd'hui qu'est ce que tu fais dans
la vie bat - tout droit de vous raconter
toute ma vie comme vient de le faire
ça fait très difficile de répondre à
cette question et pareil si on me
demande et oui mais ta vie
professionnelle et vie privée c'est quoi
bah moi de vous dire je sais quelle
activité génère un revenu bien sûr je
peux vous dire aussi qu'elle activités
prennent le plus de temps
mais après ou est ce qu'on met
l'association par exemple j'utilise plus
de compétences et puis il ya plus de
pression que par exemple le doublage et
pourtant j'ai passé moins de temps ça
génère pas de revenu et tout donc on
s'est un petit peu compliqué donc le
modèle que moi je vous propose qui qui
est sous jacent dans tout ce que je vais
me présenter en fait extrêmement simple
et tout le monde peut l'appliquer
il se compose de trois composantes la
première le temps vous avez 24 heures
par jour 365 jours par an c'est tout
facile on va dire 12 heures effectives
parce que le temps de manger le temps de
se doucher et cuisiner machin dormir on
va dire que vous avez en moyenne 12
heures par jour vous pouvez faire ce que
vous voulez l'autre chose c'est la
notion d'objectif qu'est ce que voulait
faire qui est ce que vous voulez être ou
est ce que vous voulez aller danser
après c'est à vous de déterminer aussi
c'est quelque chose qui est vivant vous
n'avez pas le définir à 20 ans et le
garder jusqu'à 70 ça marche pas comme ça
et le troisième concept c'est la notion
c'est la notion d'activité et j'aime
bien le mot activités parce que c'est un
mot neutre et j'entends par activité
tout ce que vous faites tous les jours
qui prend du temps ça peut être ça peut
générer un revenu ça peut vous coûter de
l'argent ça peut être des voyages des
trucs vous faites sur votre temps libre
votre travail peu importe tout ce que
vous faites tout ce que vous faites qui
utilise du temps et la relation entre
ces trois éléments elle est simple
chaque activité
et un certain coût en temps et vous
rapproche plus ou moins de vos objectifs
et donc moi le modèle que j'ai mis en
place celui qui est sous jacent à tous
que je me présentais c'est très simple
je m'assure que le temps que j'investis
dans chaque activité est directement
proportionnel aux objectifs qu'elle
couvre formulé autrement plus une
activité vous rapproche d'un objectif ou
de plusieurs objectifs et plus vous
allez investir de temps dans et a
contrario c'est une activité n'est
absolument pas lié à ce qui vous
intéresse ou peu vous allez limité pour
la supprimer complètement alors dit
comme ça c'est relativement simple
si je reprends de nouveau un exemple de
ma vie je reviens sur sur le doublage le
voiceover
ça me permet de générer un revenu et
c'est à peu près tout parce que je fais
depuis chez moi ça ne fait apparemment
de rencontrer des gens ça me permettent
pas vraiment développer mon réseau
donc du coup j'ai limité le temps que je
passe dessus j'y passe quelques heures
par semaine ça ne permet d'en tirer un
revenu qui tient la route parfait
l'association c'est quelque chose qui
est important pour moi ça me permet
d'utiliser les compétences donc du coup
j'investis beaucoup plus de temps dessus
même si en pratique ça tourne plutôt
bien donc j'ai pas besoin n'ont pu y
passer des heures les voyages j'étais
par exemple en amérique du nord il ya
quoi il ya quelques semaines et dans
deux jours je vais partir au japon pour
un mois pourquoi parce que j'ai des amis
là-bas que j'ai envie d'y passer du
temps et de me créer des contacts et vu
que mon revenu je peux le générer un
petit peu où je veux et quand je veux ça
fonctionne ensemble et en fait toute
l'idée c'est de créer en fait un puzzle
et ça c'est vraiment à vous de le
définir vous prenez vos objectifs vous
regardez les activités et ensuite vous
essayer de tout faire fonctionner
ensemble je vous ai parlé du mien et
chacun de définir le sien en gros alors
quelles conséquences
il y en a plusieurs ça dépend beaucoup
de vos objectifs de comment est ce que
vous créez ce puzzle moyenne à 3 sur les
cas j'aimerais m'attarder 3 que j'ai que
j'ai vu que j'ai vécu la première c'est
comme commencer à raisonner comme ça
vous allez très vite identifié là où
vous perdez du temps en moi j'ai un
exemple tout bête il ya quelques années
j'utilise je joue aux jeux vidéo pour
pour me détendre et j'avais en fait
cette tendance a absolument vouloir
finir le jeu à 100% je suis sûr qu'ils
sont pareils d'ici veulent absolument
que je choque tous les objets cachés que
j'aille tuer les 10000 poulet récupère
les 110 pièces d'or fin vous savez
comment ça marche et en fait eu un soir
je me souviens donc j'ai fait mon truc
j'ai tué mes dix mille poulet où je sais
plus quoi et j'ai posé la manette et je
me suis dit là j'aime passer deux heures
à récupérer le trophée x
alors que dans ma liste d'objectifs en
fait ça n'apparaît nulle part c'est pas
du tout mon truc qui me permet qu'il me
rapproche de ce que j'ai envie de faire
donc passé deux heures à jouer à me
détendre à regarder un film et tout ça
pas de problème parce que c'est
nécessaire ça fait partie des choses qui
sont importantes penser à autre chose
par contre les deux heures
supplémentaires que j'ai passé sur voila
tu aimais voulais c'était de gaspiller
en fait et ça c'est j'ai pris un exemple
très concret mais quand vous commencez à
comprendre que votre temps est limité et
que toutes les activités que vous faites
vous rapproche ou pas de vos objectifs
vous avez très rapidement identifier ou
vous passer trop de temps peut-être pas
assez etc
deuxième conséquence importante la
perspective que vous avez sur la notion
de monter son entreprise sur la notion
d'emploi d'être employés moi je me
souviens que quand j'étais à eux quand
j'étais là dans ses rangs là il ya
quelques années je voyais ma question
c'est est et ouest que ça c'est mon
métier de rêve et ce que j'ai envie de
bosser dans cette entreprise est ce que
c'était à chaque fois qu'ils ont une
offre d'emploi s'étaient tout de suite
la grande question est ce que c'est ce
truc là que j'ai envie de faire oui nom
pareil monter son entreprise super away
mais il ya beaucoup d'heures comment est
ce que je vais faire qu'est ce que j'ai
envie de vendre etc
en fait on peut éclater être à son
compte ou être employé en tout un tas de
petits éléments parce que finalement on
est en train de parler d'un certain
niveau de revenus on parle d'un cerf de
certains horaires on parle de certains
collègues ont peur de certaines
responsabilités etc
c'est un package en fait vous pouvez
voir comme ça et quand vous commencez à
comprendre que le temps que vous
investissez sur vos activités et limité
que savoura proche de vos objectifs
ou pas vous allez commencer à éclater en
fait une offre
on va prendre une offre d'emploi tout
bêtement au lieu de vous dire est ce que
ça que j'ai envie de faire ou pas vous
allez vous dire ok ça par rapport à mai
l'objectif ça colle ou ça colle pas et
parfois il faut se lancer et parfois
juste une description de d'un poste ça
suffit pas alors vous allez avoir des
entretiens des trucs qui vous permettent
de mieux comprendre en quoi consiste le
métier mais parfois il faut se lancer il
faut commencer à travailler mais à voir
la discipline de revenir à sa liste
d'objectifs et de dire est-ce que ça
colle ou est-ce que ça colle pas quoi et
après de se dire on me demande combien
de temps si c'est un temps plein ou non
des 35 heures 40 heures par semaine
est ce que le temps qu'on vous demande
est proportionnel à ce que vous gagnez
parfois oui
allez-y foncez puis parfois non moi je
sais que j'ai toujours pas trouvé une
activité ou sur laquelle je peux
investir 40 heures après c'est moi mais
ça dépend des gens donc dans mon cabas
j'ai cité donc les différentes activités
sur lesquelles sur lesquels je
m'investis je sais que j'ai encore reçu
trois offres d'emploi ou travail de
consultant depuis août
mais à chaque fois on dit ouais ce que
tu veux bosser pour nous faut que tu
poses 40 heures par semaine
tu bosses depuis chez toi tu es flexible
machin ouais sauf que je suis déjà
flexible à l'amp demande d'investir 40
heures par semaine ça me permet pas de
rencontrer des gens ça me permet pas de
voyager sa fin par rapport à mes
objectifs ça couvre leurs revenus c'est
à peu près tout mais ce que j'ai envie
de passer 40 heures par semaine juste à
couvrir un revenu non donc du coup j'ai
refusé les trois offres et puis le
dernier point qui est peut-être le plus
important c'est que ce modèle là ne
dépend pas de vous en êtes dans votre
vie puisqu'il se base sur le temps long
le temps est toujours le même la notion
d'activité pareil et vos objectifs qui
évolue avec le temps mais qui sont
toujours là y en a toujours
et donc pourquoi est ce que c'est
important parce que quand vous allez
faire face à des situations de crise et
quand je pense à cri je pense par
exemple la rupture je pense au décès
d'un proche je pense maladie grave tous
ces trucs qui en fait mais tape la barre
vos objectifs actuels vos objectifs
futurs ou dit qu'est ce que je vais
faire maintenant de ma vie eh ben ce
modèle à lui il est toujours présent et
en plus il peut vous aider à
reconstruire derrière alors là à nouveau
je vais reprendre un exemple basé sur ma
vie moi il m'est arrivé un truc comme ça
on mais là cette année
alors il ya toute une phase comme
d'habitude de deuil de douleurs etc
enfin bon bref je suis en train de dire
que tout d'un coup tout va fonctionner
et qu'il y aura plus jamais de problème
c'est pas ça mais par contre quand vous
arrivez à la phase de re de
reconstruction pardon bas au lieu de
vous dirai ce que je garde mon boulot
est ce que je quitte cette ville est ce
que font ces grandes questions là parce
que c'est ça en fait on est en train de
se poser ces questions-là vous pouvez
regarder votre liste d'objectifs et vous
dire ok est-ce que je passe du temps sur
ce qui est important pour moi
moi par exemple je me suis dit bon
l'association c'est cool mais j'ai fait
le tour
donc tant que je suis à göteborg en
suède je m'en occupe mais bon le jour où
je pars je pars quoi je laisse tomber
mon entreprise ouais c'est sympa mais
j'en ai marre de passer du temps à
chercher des clients une passe qui
marche donc du coup je vais faire
tourner sa passe est sur autre chose
les voyages par contre extrêmement
important du coup je me suis dit ça je
vais lui mettre plus de temps j'ai des
objectifs que j'ai même mis entre
parenthèses en disant ça je sais pas
trop encore c'est encore trop frais je
sais pas ce que je vais en faire bon
d'accord et je garde un oeil dessus
la noce l'homme cette histoire de séries
d'animation me suis dit ça c'est
extrêmement important je peux pas
laisser ça en arrière-plan maintenant ça
devient quelque chose de principal et du
coup j'ai investi plus de temps dessus
c'est à nouveau c'est à vous de le
définir
mais disons que ça vous donne une base à
partir de laquelle reconstruire
votre vie derrière et ça je pense que
c'est extrêmement important alors pour
conclure vous doutez bien que j'ai fait
que toucher le que toucher la surface
est un sujet qui est extrêmement vaste
on pourrait parler de comment mettre en
place un système financier qui tient la
route
comment définir vos objectifs pour ceux
qui ont du mal je sais que moi il m'a
fallu un moment parlé des difficultés
parce que j'ai jamais dit que ce serait
facile d vous faites quelque chose qui
n'est pas commun des boues sortir des
sentiers battus vous avez vous heurter à
l'hostilité à l'incompréhension au
besoin d'être extrêmement créatif de
tracer un chemin la ville en n'existe
pas mais bon le temps est limité donc du
coup je voulais avant tout partager avec
vous l'idée le concept et j'espère
peut-être que certains d'entre vous le
prendre au vous rentrerez chez vous et
vous regardez vos choix passés présents
et futurs
à la lumière de cette nouvelle
perspective parce que peut-être que pour
certains d'entre vous se demander qu'est
ce que je veux faire dans la vie ou
comment est ce que je vais divisé ma vie
entre vie privée et vie professionnelle
c'est peut-être pas la bonne question et
si vous poser la mauvaise question vous
trouvera jamais la bonne réponse
souvenez vous que vous avez une vie à
vivre
vous avez une histoire à écrire la vôtre
celle de personne d'autre c'est votre
responsabilité personne ne fera pour
vous et donc selon moi on n'a pas
vraiment de temps à perdre dans des
processus dans des systèmes qui ont été
conçus par d'autres pour d'autres tant
mieux si vous pouvez utiliser par
exemple le système scolaire des choses
qui pendant un temps fonctionne qui font
partie de votre histoire très bien ça
marche vous avez juste à suivre le
mouvement
par contre faut pas hésiter à dévier
quand bassaïev vous n'êtes plus dans la
bonne direction si votre objectif il est
là-bas faut savoir avoir les tripodes de
partir souvenez vous que le temps est la
ressource la plus importante que vous
ayez les jours les heures les minutes
qui passent ne reviennent jamais et donc
même si je vous souhaite bien sûr de
vivre une vie longue et prospère et
celle de cette planète il vous reste une
poignée d'années à vivre 60 70 si vous
avez de la chance
donc la question la plus importante la
seule question qui importe c'est à quoi
voulez-vous que ces années ressemble
merci
[Applaudissements]